in the previous video we have seen how
algebra makes our life very easy
it helps us write long phrases in a very
short way using variables that's the
beauty of algebra how do we write the
sum of three and seven using numbers we
just write it as three plus seven let me
modify the question a bit how do we
write the sum of a number and 7 since
this number is unknown we use a variable
in its place and write it as X plus 7
both these are called expressions as
this involves only numbers it's called a
numerical expression and because it
involves variables it's called an
algebraic expression now look at this
line sum of a number and 7 equals 12 now
it gets interesting let's break it into
parts sum of a number and 7 it can be
written as X plus 7 equals 12 can be
written as equal to 12 we wrote this
phrase as X plus 7 equals 12
is this an expression no that's not the
case this is called an equation since it
has an equal to sign it's called so
because we are equating two sides the
left-hand side and the right-hand side
what are the different parts of an
equation this is called the variable
that is we are expected to find and
these two numbers are called constants
as their value remains constant
there are also operators like addition
and subtraction so these are the
important parts of an equation remember
the equal to sign divides the equation
into two sides the left-hand side and
the right-hand side
you